aujourd'hui le message qu'on veut
envoyer c'est qu'on désire nous aussi
reprendre les pourparlers avec le
gouvernement du québec mais ce pas à
n'importe quelle condition
on veut également dans un deuxième temps
a déploré le les différents gestes
violents qu'on a vu au courant des
derniers jours continue et d'éviter les
étudiants au calme on comprend que la
tension est palpable on comprend que
beaucoup de frustration à ce moment dans
l'air mais je pense qu'il faut le
meilleur moyen de faire passer notre
message auprès de la population des
ministres c'est de rester pacifiques
donc encore une fois l'on veux
mentionner qu'on désire reprendre les
pourparlers reprendre les négociations
avec le gouvernement du québec pour
régler la crise et qui nous oppose mais
c'est pas n'importe quelles conditions
voilà donc on annonce que domaine
reprendre les pourparlers à 14 heures
comme le dit si bien la ministre ce
qu'on lui a posé la question à savoir
qu'il a représentée au sein la table de
négociations nous choisirons également
des délégations au sein de cette table
et dont nous annonçons que la délégation
d'affaires comprendra deux membres de la
classe ainsi que deux modes de l'afp
présent à la table de discussion le
vendredi donc demain à 14 heures il est
clair que de notre côté les
enfantillages ont assez duré la muse de
l'éducation de se comporter en mines et
ce non pas en maîtresse d'école pour
nous le fait de voir le finalement les
manifestations dégénérer c'est lié
directement aux conditions dans
lesquelles on se situe actuellement le
fait que le ministre la ministre a tardé
d'appeler les gens à la table de
discussion et donc il est temps que ça
cesse nous prenons nos responsabilités
donc nous demandons que la tam se tient
à partir de 14h avec toutes les
associations étudiantes pour régler le
conflit